كل يوم في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
المرحله النهائيه
للعمليه السياسيه في السودان وقالت الاليه
الثلاثيه الميسره للحوار في السودان
والمشكله من الاتحاد الافريقي ومجموعه
ايجاد وبعثه الامم المتحده قالت هذه
الاليه ان هذه المرحله سيحضرها المدنيون
والعسكريون الذين وقعوا على اتفاق الاطار
السياسي
الاليه ان المساورات ستتركز على خمس قضايا
على مدى اربعه ايام لدراسه خريطه طريق
لاحياء عمليه تفتيت ما يعرف بتمكين النظام
الرئيسي المعزول عمر البشير
هذه المرحله من الحوار العام
كريم
بين المكون المركزي وقوه المدنيه في
الخامس من الشهر
الماضي والمتبعه معنا من الخرطوم مراسلنا
نزار البقدوي اهلا بك من جديد نزار في اي
ظروف ستجري هذه المرحله النهائيه من هذه
العمليه السياسيه وكيف ينظر اليها اطرافها
[موسيقى]
يعني هذه العمليه السياسيه التي ستبدا هذا
اليوم المرحله النهائيه منها تاتي في ظل
تعقيدات سياسيه همم معترف بها من قبل
الفاعلين الداخليه وحتى الخارجيين تاتي
ايضا في ظل رغبات دوليه هذه الرغبات صدرت
يوم الامس على لسان السفاره البريطانيه
هنا في الخرطوم التي قالت بانها ترغب فعلا
اتفاقا سياسيا حقيقيا في السودان يمهل
لحكومه مدنيه ومنها الى مرحله الانتخابات
حتى تتدفق المساعدات الدوليه الى السودان
بعد ان توقفت بعد الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر للعام الماضي الان هذا الاتفاق
يدخل همم حيز همم التفعيل السياسي بعد
مناقشه خمس قضايا رئيسيه لكن هذه القضايا
الخمس الرئيسيه مريم تاتي ايضا في ظل
الانقسام سياسي حول جدوى وطبيعه واهم هذا
الاتفاق الذي من المفترض ان يوقع بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع هنالك قتل همم ترفض بصوره
واقعيه هذا الاتفاق على راسها الكتله
الديمقراطيه وهنالك القوه الحريه والتغيير
القوه الوطنيه وهنالك تحالف الجذريين الذي
يتزعمه الحزب الشيوعي وبطبيعه الحال
تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه السودانيه التي
تنشط هذا الشهر في جدول تصعيدي يناهض هذا
الاتفاق الذي سيوقع بين المدنيين وبين
العسكريين في الجانب الاخر هنالك ترحيب من
قبل المجلس المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير
الذي وقع مع العسكريين على هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي هو يبدا مساء هذا اليوم في همم
بدايه مناقشه القضايا الخمس الرئيسيه
ستقوم بحضور رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقيادات المدنيه
وسفارات اجنبيه هذا اليوم بقاعه الصداقه
العمليه السياسيه نحو الامام والبعض يتوقع
ان لا تثمر من واقع الاختلافات الحادثه
الان بين القوى السياسيه ومن واقع ايضا
الجمود الذي لازمه العمليه السياسيه
وهنالك معطى اخر ايضا همم مريم لابد ان
يوضع في الحسبان وهو انعدام الثقه بين
المكونات السياسيه سواء تلك التي بدات
اليوم في التوقيع والاستمرار مع العسكريين
وتلك التي تناهض هذا الاتفاق العسكري وبين
المساريين الرافض والموافق تمضي هذه
الازمه السياسيه في تفاعلاتها والكل الان
لينظر بعين المراقبه لما الالات هذه
العمليه السياسيه التي ستبدا مساء اليوم
هنا في العاصمه السودانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك